i'm happy
to introduce
demesa sabis
you probably know um or most of you know
all about him um
his bio is
you know
he
was a chess prodigy
he
doing a phd in neuroscience
he then
came to mit he
founded a deep mind
they developed
alphago
they developed
before that atari games they developed
alpha zero
and then more recently alpha fold and
yes
in the meantime received so many prices
and so on
but anyway that's you can read all of
this
what i want to explain is why
it's coming back to mit every three
years or so since 2010
to give us an update about the state of
ai and deep mind
and the reason is that
in 2009 he came to spend
a few months as a visiting
postdoc
in my lab
and then this went pretty well and
as you can see from
this recommendation that i wrote up
there
and he applied to a welcome fellowship
that he got with the idea of
then spending the next five years
working between london and cambridge
here and
you know fortunately or unfortunately
he spent of these five years only a few
months
with your welcome fellowship and but
then it started declined
and uh
and this was 2010
i think and
and and so in 2011
we had here actually the initial
session was exactly in this classroom we
had a symposium that josh tenenbaum and
i organized by the named brain
brains mines and machine was for the one
of the five symposia for the 150 years
of mit in 2011
and it started with a first session in
this classroom that was titled the
golden age
of ai
and so you can see here sidney brenner
and marvin minsky and noam chomsky and
emilio betsy and patrick winston at the
end
and this was by the way the first and
only time as far as i know that marvin
minsky and noam chomsky were together on
a panel
which is pretty amazing
and this was the first day the third day
was the marketplace for intelligence
and so
there were
you know the big gun like
microsoft and
google and ibm speaking but there was
also startups uh or other companies i
think cobie spoke convicia and
i'm
upload spock and damaged them is looked
a bit younger but
and and so
after that i asked him
to become a member of the
advisory committee of cbmm the center
for brains minds and machines
then
we got with josh and several other mit
with funding for nsf for 10 years it's
actually
2023 is the
last year of nsf nsf funding for the
cbmm
and
demis has been
a great advisor together with all the
great advisor in our external advisory
committee that will meet actually
tomorrow
to tell us what to do next
and and so that's why that means he's
coming back this is a little piece of
his bio that is not usually known and
davis i'm very glad
to give you
the stage
[Music]
great thanks tommy for that great
introduction
i i stayed over with tommy on sunday
evening and he was saying that he found
in the attic all of these um ancient
documents of deepmind from way back in
2010-11 that i've completely forgotten
about and lost track of but tommy still
had somewhere so it was great
reminiscing about old times
um
so it's always fantastic to be back here
it's been it's been a few years now of
course um uh with the pandemic
but it's always wonderful to be back at
mit
uh and to talk to all of you so today
what i'm going to discuss is
mostly our latest work which is alpha
fold
and the impact it's had there and
hopefully those of you biologists in the
in the audience have have found it
useful yourselves and maybe using it
be great to hear your feedback on that
in the q and a session um but before i
talk about alpha fault specifically and
actually a lot of
the other work that uh
we are using
in in the various different sciences
i'll briefly mention some of the other
work we've had um we had a bit of a
golden year i would say last year in
terms of applying ai to all sorts of
hard problems in the in the sciences um
but i was going to sort of also just
recapitulate a few of the things that
have led up to being us being able to do
this it's a sort of um you know it's
been a kind of 10 year well i guess 12
years now process to get to this point
uh where we're finally at the point now
i think where we can apply ai very
meaningfully to
scientific discovery itself uh which was
always my aim with deep mind
from the very beginning
so i just want to sort of thread the
needle view on terms of like how those
the different work we've done in the
past um largely on games uh then
culminated uh in the kind of work that
we're doing now
so as tommy said um you know we started
deepmind in 2010 uh with a very
audacious sort of vision um
you know the plan was to effectively
build a kind of apollo program effort uh
for building artificial general
intelligence or
human level artificial intelligence
and back in 2010 uh none of you will
remember this now but um you know ai was
sort of uninvestable i would say and uh
certainly a kind of backwater
and it's kind of amazing to see what's
happened in a relatively short space of
time you know within a decade really uh
it's gone from that to perhaps one of
the you know hottest areas of technology
science and
and also commercial investing so it's
kind of amazing and it's been a sort of
privilege to be at the at the vanguard
of that uh and and and be part of
pushing that uh transformation forward
um and in a way i mean we always of
course plan for success but um i think
even we've been pretty surprised by
how quickly
things have progressed and where we've
got to today
so the
mission statement of deepmind
was to solve intelligence and to use it
to advance science and benefit humanity
and we've had this in mind from the very
beginning this has all sorts of
implications about what we would think
about
when we use the term solving
intelligence what do we mean um well you
know i've been trained as a
neuroscientist and as a computer
scientist and and and really deep mind
was the uh in the early days was an
intersection really of the best ideas of
from computer science and and ai and
machine learning and the best ideas um
that we had at that time from uh systems
neuroscience uh and that's partly why i
was um i was working with uh you know in
tommy's group because obviously uh his
group does both of those two things and
by solving intelligence what we mean is
we'd like to fundamentally understand
the phenomena of intelligence and then
uh of course recreate that artificially
to create artificial general
intelligence
and now our thinking was that if this
was done in a very general way
then in theory one should be able to
apply the technologies that come out of
that the algorithms that come out of
that process to a whole wide range of
challenging tasks after all that is what
the human brain does
obviously our only existence proof of
general intelligence that we have
and
and there's no you know i don't think
theoretical reason why that should not
be possible
so the type of approach we took at
deepmind which was very early if you
think about that in 2010 and now of
course is all the rage is a learning
systems approach uh and it's turned out
i've transpired obviously over the last
decade that they're incredibly powerful
and they have huge potential these types
of learning systems
so of course this i think of it as two
components really um although there are
many types of learning systems but of
course the one we specialize in at
deepmind is called deep reinforcement
learning so one way you can think about
this at least the way i think about this
is if an agent or an ai system on the
left here finds itself in some kind of
environment or some sort of data stream
and it's observing uh getting
observations of that data stream and um
and i think you know the first job of
them of the ai system is to basically
build a model of that environment uh
from that data or that experience um and
that could be a continually updating
thing uh if this is an active learning
agent so that's the first uh a job of
the ai system i would say then the
second job where we use reinforcement
learning for this but there are other
approaches too is to
once you've built that model of the
environment you can use that model to
learn how to achieve a specific goal or
maximize a reward
usually specified by the designers of
the system
within that
environment and reinforcement does the
reinforcement learning does that by sort
of a sophisticated process of trial and
error uh in order to figure out uh what
action best at what action to take that
would best get it towards its goal
and at least in a in an active learning
system or an agent system uh this is a
this is an active learning process so
actions are taken that may drive a a new
uh change in the environment which in
itself may drive uh a new observation
so the the cool thing about these
systems the parallel systems is that
they can discover potentially new
knowledge
from first principles for themselves
through this process of trial and error
so of course if one thinks about that
then this might be incredibly powerful
in certain domains um for example like
science
so obviously as your all of you will
probably know alphago was our big
landmark success so i uh with this type
of system um probably the still the most
famous demonstration to date of a deep
rl system um
and um just to remind those of you who
have not heard about that of course this
is our program to play the game of go
um and we know that go uh was you know
it's super hard for computers to play
until alphago came along because of its
enormous search base and the fact that
it was it's a very esoteric game
so it's very difficult to write down a
handcrafted evaluation function uh in
the way that chess programs are written
and i think the reason this is is
because go is actually at the edge of
difficulty level that even humans can
cope with i would say whereas chess is
probably just below that limit it's
slightly less complex than um than go
and i think uh go players deal with this
complexity
by relying heavily on their intuition
and their pattern matching skills rather
than their explicit calculation skills
because it's just too complicated uh for
us to do that
and that's of course the reason why it's
so difficult
to program these evaluation functions is
even the world's best players um would
not be able to describe to you precisely
how they are evaluating a position in
terms of a bunch of rules that could
maybe be coded
so we built these systems and then the
the the descendants of alphago alphago
zero and then alpha zero and then more
recently mu zero and they all um sort of
uh uh basically use this underlying
approach that i'm going to describe here
which is really more the way that alpha
zero and alpha go zero worked
but you can think of as the whole way
all of these types of systems work
and it's pretty simple to describe so
what happens is you start with a neural
network that's basically random
and it's trained through
hundreds of thousands sometimes millions
of games of self-play to get better at
evaluating a position uh whether it's
good or not for the opponent or for the
for the for the agent uh and also to
predict what are the right the kind of
most likely moves uh that should be made
in a position uh so that it can narrow
down this enormous search space
and so what happens is you start with
version one let's say of the of the
system and um it's going to be pretty
bad almost random at playing you you do
a hundred thousand um self-play games uh
that generates a new data set and you
use that data set of games to train a
second neural network uh uh version two
and version two tries to predict who you
know which side will win from a certain
position in those games uh and also what
type of move
you know what's you know try guess which
kind of move is made by the v1 system
so you train up v2 and then you have a
little mini tournament between v2 and v1
uh 100 games or so and there's some kind
of win threshold where you feel like
v2 needs to beat v1 by a certain
threshold we set that 55 win rate and
then we regard that as significantly
stronger the v2 than the v1
now if that happens and and v2 does beat
v1 55 or more of the time then you
replace uh v1 with v2 and you do this
whole cycle again and you generate a new
set of data but this data will be
slightly higher quality because now it's
v2 that's generating that data and then
you turn a version three
right and um and then you do the little
mini tournament and you and you and you
go again now if um v2 does not beat v1
in that first mini tournament you
continue to generate more data with v1
so you do another 100 000 games and now
you've got 200 000 uh games to train the
next v2 star one could call it uh and um
and then eventually what we find is that
v2 does eventually beat v1 and in fact
if once one does this around 17 times
depending on which game it is uh or that
kind of order 17 to 20 times you go from
random play to better than human world
champion in any two-player game
and that's the system
so it's pretty elegant and we sort of
generalized it fully to all two-player
games not just go but any two-player
perfect information game
so this will become relevant in a minute
when we discuss about how to apply these
techniques to science if you think of go
really as
when you boil down what what alphago is
it's uh you know go is this enormous
search space more positions than there
are atoms in the universe impossible to
exhaustively search or boot by brute
force or any brute force method
to find out what the right
path through the go game is
so what you can think of is the neural
net has learned this sort of model of
the environment in this case go
positions and likely go moves
and how good go positions are and that
constrains this enormous search space so
instead of having to search this entire
search space
it just searches the monte carlo tree
search only needs to search you know a
small tiny fraction that this in blue
of the of the possibilities and then of
those of course um it picks the best one
that evaluate that comes out as the best
evaluation this this path in pink
and that's the path that is picked um
once the thinking time runs out
now this this um uh program was
obviously normally powerful we beat the
18 times world champion in a very famous
match in 2016 uh in seoul and um
which was watched by a couple hundred
million people and we won that match 4-1
um and you know it was proclaimed to be
a decade before its time but as those of
you familiar with this will know that
what was more important was actually how
alphago uh won that match um and the
fact that it came up with original uh go
strategies and and go motifs including
most famously move 37 in game two which
is here on the right and encircled in
red and um suffice to say that this
piece uh was put on the fifth line you
can see here the fifth line from the
edge of the board and this early in the
game you should never play on the fifth
line um we don't really know why but
that's the rules of of of of uh of sort
of go masters will tell you you should
only play a move like this on the fourth
line or the third line definitely not
the fifth line um of course that's all
changed now with alphago doing this and
obviously the subsequent five plus years
now um these these all these alphago
games have been studied to death and
they're sort of there's there's you know
there are many many books now written
about this and it's changed go theory um
and of course the interesting thing
about this was that
this this move 37 stone 100 moves later
roughly was in exactly the right
position to decide the game because the
fighting from the bottom left of this
position spread across the whole board
and then move the mu 37 stone happened
to be in the perfect position to decide
that that battle and then win alphago
the game
so this is very interesting so this is
clearly an original strategy um but we
can come back to as well also in the q a
about what does this mean about
creativity so um you know maybe just to
mention a little bit about that i think
ai systems today are very good have been
very good at for a long time on
interpolation so you can think of that
as you know distinguishing between cats
pictures of cats and dogs and you show
you know the system millions of cats
millions of dogs and it kind of
effectively builds a sort of prototype
of what a cat and what a dog looks like
and then so that's kind of like
interpolation some kind of average of
all those examples um and you know kind
of create a template out of that this i
would say is more like extrapolation so
these
these these strategies have never been
played before by human players right so
this is not just interpolation some kind
of averaging of what we know is good
it's it's it's true i would say
extrapolation so i think that is some
form of creativity uh one would have to
say but on the other hand there's i
think there's a further level to go
which i don't think ai systems can do
which one could call true invention or
out of the box thinking
and for me that would be not coming up
with just an original strategy and go
but inventing go
right so we don't have any systems that
can invent go or invent chess um and uh
that's a whole nother level and you know
it's interesting to speculate well what
would be missing from that i think
partially we wouldn't know how to even
describe that to an ai system uh know in
in a way that isn't very high level uh
conceptual and uh our current systems
don't um really deal with that very well
so i think there's one more so i think
we're starting to encroach into the
boundaries of what
one may call or think of as creative
but there's several more i think levels
still to go
so if you're interested in this uh of
course there's the alphago film that's
now on youtube and you i think uh you
know if you're interested in the kind of
the human story if you like behind
alphago i highly recommend uh this
award-winning documentary
so then with alpha zero as i was
mentioning we we generalize this next to
and this is in general the way we we
tend to i think this is a good approach
to engineering sciences usually you um
at least what we do at deepmind is you
try and focus on performance first so
you try and get can you actually
master go at all
then once that performance is reached
you throw out you start throwing out
components of the system to make it more
more general less and less specific to
that particular task
while still keeping that performance
level up right
and then finally which is the stage
we're getting to in certain of our
systems like uh like alpha zero and a
bit alpha fold you can also do analytics
on that system and try and understand at
a deep level sort of open up the black
box and and and find out um how exactly
it's working and what is the knowledge
that it's how is it not representing the
knowledge that it has
so alpha zero amazingly uh within a few
hours um training for nothing would be
the best programs are available in any
of these other games and these programs
are already better than world champion
human world champion level including
you'll see at the bottom here alphago
all the versions of alphago itself so
alpha zero uh would beat all versions of
alphago
and um that's quite interesting in
itself right so this idea of
generalization can also give you a
little bit more performance too uh is
the lesson that we also took from this
which is quite an interest you know
maybe slightly counter-intuitive
of course because i'm an ex-chess player
um chess was always the thing i was
eventually once gonna want to apply this
to
um and again in chess not only was it
exceptionally strong beating stockfish
eight which was at the time the world
champion chess computer of the
traditional type
but it
sort of invented a new style of chess
where it favored mobility over
materiality so almost all chess programs
until uh alpha zero favored material so
you know the the classic cliche is that
you know computer grabs a pawn because
if it sees some material that it can
take it will try and grab it even if it
then has to sort of hang on for dear
life
and defend and of course computers are
very good at defending positions because
they don't make any mistakes tactical
mistakes
so um but this was always considered to
be very ugly way of playing chess so no
one would say oh we've seen this
wonderful beautiful chess computer game
you know they were ugly they were
effective but ugly and so this is what
changed about alpha zero is not only was
it better they were beautiful games or
at least considered to be beautiful like
this game here where alpha zero is white
and you can see what it's done is it
sacrificed a lot of pieces you know an
exchange and some pawns um in order to
totally imprison the black pieces and
sort of block all the black pieces in so
in fact none of the black pieces can
move without losing something even
though there's the black is winning on
material here uh and in in in chess
that's called zugswang that kind of
position where um
no you know any move you make
makes your position worse and this kind
of position was never seen before and
you did you know the famous youtube
chess commentators called this the
immortal zugzwan games no one had ever
seen a position like this where you've
got such powerful pieces like the queens
and the rooks and they can't do anything
um so this is pretty incredible um how
is alpha zero doing this well my
speculation and we've also analyzed it
with some of the ex-world chess
champions and we sort of opened up the
system to them like vladimir kramnik
and you know they helped us understand
that and we've we've written a paper
recently analyzing seeing if we can
reverse engineer alpha xero and find out
what what the rules are that it's built
implicitly in alpha xero
and it's obviously better at evaluating
positions than chess engines and the
reason is is because it doesn't have to
overcome these inbuilt rules
so in order you know if you think about
why chess computers don't sacrifice
their pieces a lot it's because they
have inbuilt tables uh valuation tables
that tell them rooks are worth five
points knights are worth three points so
in order for it to sacrifice a rook for
a night it will have to work out
explicitly through its brute force
search that it's going to get the two
points back somehow right and if it
can't work that out within its event
horizon then it won't do it whereas
alpha zero doesn't have those inbuilt
rules so it can it's much freer to take
into account the sort of contextual
factors of the current position and just
say in this position that knight is
super powerful it's on an outpost so and
my rook's passive so i'm just going to
swap them it doesn't have to overcome
this in-built uh bias if you like
it's also better at balancing different
factors against each other so one of the
problems is rule-based systems is that
you have maybe a thousand rules at this
point in the best chess programs and you
not only are those rules are they the
right rules and are they um are they
they expressed correctly but also one
has to balance those rules against each
other which is a super difficult kind of
hand optimization problem
and also probably you'd want a different
balance in different positions
and of course a chest computer rules
based computer is not able to do that
right you have to have one set of
balancing rules
but alpha zero again is free to perhaps
overweight things dynamically
depending on the position
the other cool thing about these systems
is uh they do a lot less search per for
the strength of um for the strength of
uh the play so a human ground master is
you know our models are incredibly
sophisticated so we have to we only have
to do a very small amount of search to
come up with a good move so maybe a
human ground master does maybe a few
hundred moves of search if for every
decision state-of-the-art chess engines
these sort of brute force rules based
engines need to do tens of millions of
search searches per um per value per
decision and alpha zero is somewhere in
the middle it's not quite as efficient
yet as human ground masters but it's
orders of magnitude more efficient than
uh standard chess programs so if you
want to uh if you're interested to read
more about this there's obviously our
paper and also a whole book written by
the british chess champion uh about
all the different styles uh and the
implications for that for chess that
that alpha zero came up with and in fact
you don't have to just
trust my description of that here's some
you know a couple of really nice quotes
from magnus carlsen uh he's an amazing
world champ the current world champion
amazing chess player uh i've been
influenced by my heroes recently one of
which is alpha zero and i think he was
the first player really to integrate uh
these new ideas into his own play um and
uh kasparov um said you know programmers
usually reflect priorities and prejudice
of the programmes programmers but
because alpha zero learns for itself i
would say it's star reflects the truth
which is um a pretty cool thing for him
to to say
so just wrapping this up then we've been
very fortunate to make a whole bunch of
big breakthroughs in in game ai starting
with our atari work in back in 2012
actually and published in 2014 where uh
learning to play directly from the
pixels uh on the screen and no other
information alphagoa and alpha zero i
just mentioned to you and then finally
we tackled um the most what's considered
to be the most complex strategy game uh
video game uh uh uh starcraft ii and um
and reached uh uh a grand master level
at that um as well with alpha star
so that was um
you know really the history of where
we've been working on on games uh
because they're so efficient to develop
these algorithmic ideas um they're
really easy to test they're they're
safe sandboxes in a way like it doesn't
really matter if your ai does something
wrong it's just a game um but also there
are really good metrics to measure um
how are you progressing obviously uh the
win rate or the grading or you can
evaluate the the quality of the move or
um or benchmark it against the best
human players in the world in each one
of these
games
so the exciting thing was actually
our shift then in the last few years to
start to use these ai systems to explore
scientific discovery itself and what we
look for is um three uh
criteria for a suitable problem that
maybe um we can tackle with these types
of systems so
first of all we actually actively seek
out
problems that can be considered as
massive combinatorial search spaces or
state spaces and the reason we like
those
types of
uh types of problems is that that means
that exhaustive brute force approaches
will not be tractable here right so we
actively seek out these types of um
regimes
and we think we're particularly suitable
our techniques are particularly suitable
for these types of regimes
second law of all we we look for a clear
objective function or measure
to optimize against uh so that we can
he'll climb against it and uh and and
figure out if we're making progress or
not um and then finally we um look for
obviously we need enough data in which
to learn our models and or
potentially the existence of an accurate
and efficient
and um ideally it's an and uh and in
most of the things that we tackle we
usually have um both
it's very interesting actually though
that uh one of the things that we've got
very good at we in you know over the
years we've been doing this is that even
if you don't have enough data to learn
your model directly
you may have enough data in order to
cobble together a simulator and then the
simulator can then be run uh and to
generate synthetic data more synthetic
data to to augment your real data and
you can also analyze that data to see if
it's from the right distribution and the
quality of it and we've actually found
that even if the simulated data is of
less usually it's not as good quality as
the real data
as long as there's some signal in it um
it's actually still pretty useful uh and
we actually used um a little bit of a
variation on this technique for alpha
folder so it was actually an important
part of alpha fault uh which i'll come
back to in a minute
so uh so those are the three uh
objectives sort of criteria if you like
and it turns out if you use this so you
know you can use this criteria to look
at what would be useful commercially
and we have you know we now have um
hundreds of products within google
that
use deepmind technology so pretty much
any um
anything any any uh service that you use
from google will have some deepmind
technology kind of under the hood there
uh whether that's you know youtube
recommendations to your um
battery life saving on um on your
android phones uh uh or if you speak to
a google device and it speaks back to
you the uh the text-to-speech systems
are our system sort of powering that
underneath
and so um you can look into commercial
areas to see what fits these criteria
and also
interestingly scientifically and it
turns out
if you do that there are actually a lot
of things that fit
very well
with this
set of criteria
and of course the number one thing that
we try to do that ticks all of these
boxes is the protein faulting folding
problem uh i'm sure many of you will
know what this is but for those that
don't it's the problem of going from an
amino acid sequence so the sort of
genetic sequence that describes a
protein
directly to its final 3d structure
that it attains in nature or in the body
so
this is super useful why is it useful
because proteins themselves are
essential to life all of life's
mechanisms depend on proteins
and their 3d structure is thought to at
least partially determine their function
right the 3d structure of the protein
tells you quite a lot about its function
and also if you want to do things like
drug discovery
you generally want to target the surface
of the protein so you sort of need to
know it's 3d shape in order to know
what the right target areas are for you
to target your your chemical compound
against
so this is um this is the protein
folding problem um but the problem is is
that determining the structure
experimentally usually takes years of
painstaking uh experimental work right
i think the normal rule of thumb is that
you know it takes one phd student their
entire phd to do one protein and then
and oftentimes it doesn't work out
um so you know it's and it's very
difficult painstaking uh technical work
now famously uh christian and feinstein
um
about 50 years ago actually to the
almost to the day uh during his nobel
lecture acceptance speech he uh it's
almost a bit like a fermet's last
theorem situation where he sort of had a
throwaway comment in a way of like well
yes the 3d structure of a protein
should be fully determined by its amino
acid sequence so in theory uh this
should be possible um but who knows how
to do it right so uh this sparked off a
whole 50-year grand challenge or quest
in biology to try and solve this problem
right of um of protein folding
and going directly from this amino acid
sequence to the 3d structure
now one of his contemporaries levantal
uh at this point formulated what's known
as levanthal's paradox
and the question is you know the big
question for protein folding is can the
protein structure prediction problem uh
uh be solved computationally right
purely computationally and one of the
issues is levin's health paradox which
is he worked out back of envelope
estimated that there were about 10 to
the power 300 possible shapes a protein
could take an average sized protein
could take
so clearly exhaustively sampling this
is totally out of the question
and yet obviously the paradox part of
this is that in nature and in our bodies
these proteins you know spontaneously
fold sometimes in you know milliseconds
so obviously nature somehow solves this
um uh you know very efficiently right uh
in an energetic sense
so that points to the fact that this may
be
possible if we could attack it in the
right way
and for me this has been a very long
road actually to
getting to protein folding i first came
across um the problem in the 90s as a
student in cambridge um one of my uh
friends circle there was obsessed with
this problem the protein folding problem
even back then and
i remember any opportunity in the bars
and in plain pool and in the in the
college bars that he would talk about um
this problem being foundational like if
we could crack this problem then it
would open up all sorts of new avenues
for biology and it really stuck in my
mind as you described the problem and i
thought it was a fascinating problem and
i also in the back of my mind felt it
was the type of problem that ai might
one day um be suitable for ai to tackle
so i kind of filed it away because
obviously the ai techniques back in the
90s when i was still writing computer
games and doing my ai in the guys of
computer games was not ready to tackle
anything remotely like protein folding
but it was you know it really stuck to
me as a fascinating problem
and then the second time i came across
it was actually when i was doing uh my
postdoc with tommy um
here at mit and uh this game came out
called foldit some of you might remember
uh it came out i think in roughly 2008
from baker lab and it was um really i
think the best and probably still the
best example of what one would call a
citizen science game so what happened
with this game folded is that they uh
the baker lab turned the fold of the
protein folding problem into a puzzle
game
pretty pretty esoteric but quite fun
puzzle game for those of that persuasion
and um they actually you know got lots
and lots of gamers to play this game and
actually choose to make bends in the
backbone of the um
of the uh of the protein and you get an
estimate of the uh energy score right
basically and you're trying to minimize
this free energy um
what was really cool about that is that
uh well firstly i was fascinated by the
idea of you know the general public
having fun with the game but really they
were contributing to science which um
seems like you know if we could actually
tap that that would be pretty cool um
for gamers and for science i think uh
and uh so i was pretty fascinated by
that idea but also i was quite intrigued
that the best players um of uh fold it
game actually found some real structures
and actually some apparently some pretty
important ones that were published in
nature and natural structural molecular
biology in the in the subsequent years
and um
and so i was sort of thinking as i was
watching this you know looking at this
in 2010 roughly that kind of time well
what's what's happened there you know
how is this possible and you know when
you look into the kind of moves that the
players made they were making you know
local moves that were actually
increasing the energy you know the free
energy for the moment because overall
they realized later on they might be
able to
solve that you know actually globally
they like that would be lower energy and
this is the reason why greedy uh greedy
energy minimization uh uh
methods won't don't work because they
just get stuck into you know local
maxima
and so
so this uh so they're obviously able to
somehow sort of use their intuition i
mean i guess the pattern matching of
these gamers they were they weren't
biologists they were just gamers but
some of them are really good at pattern
matching and they presumably were using
that uh to sort of find their way their
intuition if you like uh to find their
way to a good fold
so then later on so that was sort of
filed away too and then later on when we
when we beat lisa dole in the soul match
um and i sort of thought back to and in
the process of that what what what were
we doing really with alphago is we
mimicked um the intuition of these go
masters right and and believe me if you
talk to these go masters you know that's
all they've ever done in their lives
like play go from the age of you know
two or three years old go to go school
then go to normal school that's you
cannot get a more highly trained mind
for a particular task than a go master
right literally i think it's kind of
impossible so if we were able to mimic
their intuition in go then why would it
not be possible to sort of do something
analogous in this protein space so that
gave me the feeling that this was um
definitely a crackable problem uh with
our techniques
so we actually started the alpha fall
project
almost the day after we got back off the
plane from seoul
with alphago and uh we actually found a
bit of recording somewhere where i was
talking to dave silva who is the project
leader now for go out in seoul and i
think we must have just won the third
match or something and we were literally
discussing it as like i think now is the
time to
push forward on on the protein folding
project
so that's what we did
another really uh uh important part of
the story was that the existence of this
competition called casp critical
assessment of protein structure
prediction and it's an amazing
competition it's sort of it's considered
to be like the olympics for protein
folding and it runs every two years uh
and it's run by this amazing group of
organizers who've been running it since
1994 so they've diligently kept this
going for close to 30 years now and what
they do is um is that as you know every
throughout a year uh experimental
departments produce new crystals and an
experimental uh determined structures of
proteins right
but over a kind of three month period
what they do is they they hold back
publishing those results
and they instead submit their newly
freshly found structures into this
competition
but it's a blind assessment so the
people the the the computational teams
that that compete in this uh uh
competition don't um know the structure
nobody in fact knows the structure other
than the group the experimental group uh
that had just found it um and then you
get you know it's quite exciting you
sort of get this uh a sequence emailed
to you and you have like one week to get
back with your best guess of the
structure uh and it's pretty fun and
it's all you do over the summer
and then at the end of all that the
organizers you know they release the
real structures and they measure how
close uh were your predictor structures
uh of all the different teams to the to
the uh to the experimentally determined
ground truth
and so you know i wanted to give a big
shout out to john malt who is the
founder of this and and the other cat
organizers who worked so hard over many
many years to um to maintain this
competition i actually think it's pretty
good model for
helping science to progress and maybe
should be thought about in other domains
too
so historically then what have been
happening at casp well it turned out
when you look back on it that
there'd been sort of very little
progress at cast for over a decade
so here on on the on on this graph uh
i'm showing you the the the winning
the the median accuracy for the winning
team at each subsequent casper
competition starting in 2006 with cash 7
and going to 2016 with casp12
and on the y-axis you can see it's a
measure of the accuracy um that the
winning team got and it's um it's called
gdt i won't go into details of how it's
calculated but you can sort of think
about you can roughly speaking it's the
percentage of residues that you have
accurately um put in the right position
within a certain tolerance certain
distance tolerance right
so obviously you're trying to get close
to 100 if you can
um
and you can see here that basically
they've been almost no progress and they
were stuck around this 40 level that's
basically a kind of useless structure so
um so this was sort of stagnated and
then we came along in uh 2018 which is
the first one we entered after working
on alpha fall for a couple of years with
alpha fold one and we made this huge
leap um and i think it kind of
revolutionized the field so we were
first it was the first time really that
um cutting-edge machine learning had
been applied at scale as the core
component of a solution um uh to the
protein folding problem and uh and alpha
for one won the competition but not only
did it win it won by almost 50
above the next best team so um and and
and you can see so that would have meant
that the teams were still tracking along
the gray bars um if it wasn't for this
new uh advance
and then of course that's not where we
wanted to stop we wanted to actually
solve the problem
and um and we had in in 2020 we actually
re-architected the whole system for the
2020 competition to reach atomic
accuracy uh and that was alpha fall two
so that was the and again another even
bigger leap um
above uh alpha fold one
so these were the results in terms of
accuracy so after fall to sort of
achieve this atomic accuracy uh at cast
14
and we were told by the organizers um
back in 2016-17 that the magic threshold
that they considered
to be the sort of threshold that needed
to be crossed was less than one angstrom
error
um that was the kind of critical
threshold for it to be competitive with
experimental methods and therefore
useful in practice so that's what we're
always aiming for so less than one
action so atomic accuracy basically the
width of a carbon atom
and alpha volt2 crossed that line and
actually achieved a 0.96 angstrom error
in the cast 14 competition for the first
time ever and you can see this was still
actually three times more accurate
than the next best systems from um some
commercial ones like from tencent but
also the best labs that work in this
area by collab zang lab and so on which
were still around the three angstrom era
in cast 14 even though they'd already
incorporated the alpha fold one advances
that obviously we'd um published um
after cast 13.
so this led to the organizers and john
malt and the organizers declaring the
structured prediction problem uh
protein folding essentially sort of
solved
and here's some examples of the outputs
of alpha fold many of you have seen this
by now but this was actually um
incredibly sort of wonderful for us to
see this uh when we got given back the
results from cast 14 and you can see how
good our predictions are the ones in
blue and the ground truth is in green
and they're overlaid over each other and
you can see that they're highly um
overlapping um including on the left
hand side this is a protein from sars uh
that even the side chains so these
little thin stalks
which are the side chains not on the
backbone of the protein
are accurately predicted too
oh sorry and um
this is the architecture for alpha fold
too um so there's there's a whole bunch
of innovations that were required here i
haven't got time to go all into all of
them but i'll give you the kind of key
takeaways if you're interested in the um
in the details there you can check out
our nature paper that has about 60 pages
of supplemental information so it's um
so maybe just a measure of how how
complex this system was
and it was by far the most complicated
system that we have ever built at
deepmind and we built some pretty
complicated systems but this is i would
say the most complex one ever
there were actually 32 component
algorithms that went into alpha fold
as i mentioned the 60 pages of si and if
there was no real silver bullet in the
end that solved protein folding actually
needed a whole host of insights and
innovations and then those innovations
had to be carefully integrated together
but the key takeaways were and the key
advances of alpha fold 2 compared to
alpha fold 1 was that firstly it was an
end-to-end system with a kind of
iterative recycling stage that actually
builds the structure piece by piece um
and builds that out and that allowed us
to go directly from um
the amino acid sequence directly to the
3d structure with alpha fold one there
was an uh intermediate step which is
that we went from the amino acid
sequence to what's called a distrogram
so a pairwise distrogram of all the
residues to all the residues and then
there was a kind of newton uh newton
method to optimize that numerical method
um that actually took the longest part
of it it took like one week per per
protein um
and both those two uh
systems had to be optimized separately
and those of you work at machine
learning will know uh be familiar with
the idea that the more end to end you
can make things generally the better it
is the kind of optimization that you do
seems to flow better and that was
definitely the case here when we were
able to optimize directly for the 3d
structure
we also used an attention-based neural
network rather than convolutional neural
network and that was key because we were
using a convolutional neural network in
in for alpha 4.1 and of course if you
think about it that's the wrong type of
bias right like obviously pixels uh on
an image if they're nearby they're
pretty correlated in their properties
but actually in fact you know that's not
true at all necessarily of of amino
acids uh that are near each other in the
sequence right obviously it completely
depends on how um the backbone uh is
going to bend round
so um so that this this attention-based
neural network would sort of infer the
implicit graph structure and then
finally we were able to build in and
this was critical evolutionary and
physics physical constraints into the
model architecture
without impacting the training and the
learning right so um uh that was you
know pretty difficult to sort of
building these constraints without
hurting the learning um but in the end
that turned out to be totally essential
so it's a kind of huge research effort
um took over five years at its peak
about 20 people highly
multi-disciplinary team so we have lots
of biologists and chemists and
physicists on the team as well as
obviously machine learning and
engineering
and the other thing to note is if the
output of a particular applied
system is in itself really valuable like
we thought this would be for biologists
then one maybe you should relax the
constraint of being general so normally
with all our machine learning research
we try and be as general as possible but
here we wanted to just solve the problem
by any means so we used all of our
general
purpose knowledge and general purpose
algorithms but then we actually built in
quite a lot of domain knowledge in this
case like the evolutionary physical
constraints
because we just wanted to solve
the problem here
in terms of speed and scale
actually this system turns out to be
incredibly fast
especially inference
so it takes about two weeks on eight
tpus roughly 150 gpus to
train
so actually fairly modest amount of
compute by today's standards uh and um
the inference is super fast so order of
minutes for an average protein on a
single gpu
so we're sort of thinking about how to
give broad access to the biology
community using uh
the system and normally what you do is
um with these systems is you put them on
a server
and then people submit their amino acid
sequences and you give them back a
structure right but actually we thought
we could do a lot better than that here
and just fold everything um for everyone
immediately uh and we wanted so we
thought okay what should we do because
it's fast enough um let's start with the
human proteome so that's what we did we
actually folded this over christmas uh i
guess 2020. uh so we sort of had this
idea straight off the competition
lots of computers are sitting idle over
christmas so
we just set them going on the human
proteome and then came back in the new
year and it was done
which is something i love about
computers you know while you'll have
your christmas lunch uh they can be
doing useful work for you and so um
so we we got all the predictions
actually we ran this twice um to make
sure and we we we got all the
predictions for all of the proteins in
the human proteome um so it's the
equivalent of the human genome right so
the human genome codes for the genes
which code for the proteins and there's
about 12 20 000 proteins in humans in
human body expressed by our genome
so we folded them all
and just so to put that in perspective
experimentally after 40 50 years of
painstaking experimental work by the
entire biology community we have um
determined about 17
of the human proteome so overnight we
doubled that to 36
with very high accuracy by very high
accuracy we mean sub-angstrom uh uh
accuracy so you know equivalent to
experimental quality um and then
furthermore 58
we um determined at high accuracy uh and
high accuracy means that um
the backbone can be trusted right maybe
not the side chains but the backbone the
general overall structure is probably
good
and that can still be useful maybe not
for certain types of things not for drug
discovery for example but it can still
be useful for fundamental research
and then one interesting thing is which
we've had a lot more data on since we've
released all this last summer is what
about the other 42 percent uh um you
know what what's going on there and
actually
it we were suspected that most of those
were not errors or deficiencies in the
system but were actually indicating
something different which is that those
proteins were unstructured in isolation
so there's a lot of proteins in the body
that actually have don't have a
structure until they interact with
whatever they're supposed to interact
with
um and they're kind of floppy um if
before that and um and actually when we
looked into this it the very was very
high correlation between the known uh
areas of intrinsic disorder and um and
where alpha fold was not good and it
knew it was not good
so this is taking it together is the
most complete and accurate picture ever
of the human proteome
and we knew we wanted biologists to use
this some biologists who maybe would
have no interest in how alpha fold
worked or not have the expertise to
worry about that but we wanted them to
trust the downstream data and to use it
in their work so we knew that it would
be really important to create a conflict
that's very simple confidence measure
that biologists could could look at and
understand really simply without
understanding anything about the
underlying
architectural details and um this is
always uh something we would like to
have in general with our machine
learning models a kind of measure of
uncertainty and how how uncertain the
system is about its own outputs but in
this case we thought it was critical and
actually we developed a system that uh
we just made a slight tweet to alpha
fold that also extracted its own
confidence metric about how confident it
was about each residue position
and greater than 90 basically means that
you can rely on its kind of experimental
level and greater than 70 is this high
accuracy regime and low in the 50 may
indicate disorder
so we folded another 20 model organisms
all the most important ones for research
the mouse
the fruit fly zebrafish and then also
some major diseases tuberculosis and
then some big plants like rice
and wheat
so and we're starting to cover more and
more of the biology space so we also did
in the first half of last year created a
database with embol ebi the european
bioinformatics institute based in
cambridge they built already a lot of
the of the big databases like uniprot
and we went to them and collaborated
with them to build the alpha fold
protein structure database to host all
of these structures in 3d and and all
the other tools and link in to all of
the other genetics tools and other tools
that biologists use every day so it just
becomes part of their everyday workflow
and we we did a big first release with
330 000 total structures um for these 20
model organisms plus the human proteome
and we put it out there for free and
unrestricted access for any use
commercial academic freely to use it to
maximize the scientific impact uh and
benefit to humanity
uh we now have more than a million
predictions in the database uh we've
we've um uh done 440 000 annotated ones
from what's called swiss prot we've also
indexed heavily early on on neglected
tropical diseases because
they're often very understudied farmer
big pharma doesn't doesn't do much
research on them because there's much
money in it but it affects millions of
people around the world and and it's
sort of terrible uh uh for their quality
of life and so on so we actually work
with the who to prioritize is what we're
doing in-house prioritize these tropical
diseases like chagas disease lesion
analysis that affect millions of people
around the world and are understudied so
that means that the non-profits can now
start with drug design um because they
have the protein structures
and we've seen it already within
barely like nine months now huge amount
being done by the community with alpha
fold for modeling very complex biology
that was not modelable before so this is
on the left here is a is a image of the
nuclear pore complex this is what allows
things in and out of your nucleus of
your cell
and it's one of the biggest proteins in
the body um it's really huge uh there's
using alpha folder as a state-of-the-art
protein disorder predictor so many
people are now using it to predict
disorder um with the w another project
with the wh show is to they identify the
top 30 pathogens that might cause a
future pandemic and they wanted all the
protein structures for those so we've
we've given that to who and actually
it's helped experiment us a lot to solve
their own protein structures
because they have sometimes they have
low resolution experimental data and if
they can also use another source of
input alpha false prediction they can
use that to combine that to resolve a
very high resolution
image of actually their protein
and there's actually now hundreds of
already other papers and applications
that have been using alpha fold both
within industry
and also academia
and the impact's been really big it got
uh listed very nicely in uh in the
breakthrough of the year by science and
and also method of the year from from
nature and the database has been used
now by over 350 000 researchers
and we think there are only about 400
000 biologists in the world so
we think that pretty much everyone has
looked at the database and is using the
database um and so it's sort of super
gratifying for us to see that
um so now you know where we're going
next there's actually over um 100
million proteins or actually nearly 200
million proteins known to science um if
you you know there's there's all these
expeditions that kind of go to the
indian ocean or somewhere like that and
they they kind of you know dip a bucket
into the water and you pull it out and
if you sequence what you get you
actually get whole loads of new proteins
and you stick them in the protein
databases but no one knows the
structures of any of these things right
so now potentially we could be in a
regime for the first time ever where
proteomics can keep up with genomics
right so uh so you can have as many
proteins from neurobatch protein
structures as abundant as we know about
genetic material
so that's really interesting what then
might one might do at a meta level about
looking at this enormous data set and
i'm very excited to see what uh protein
you know biologists uh end up doing with
that yeah so then function would be the
the next thing to look at so
um
so thanks you know i wanted to say
thanks to everybody uh amazing teams who
made alpha fall possible there's the
methods team uh everybody listed on the
left there john jumper uh leading the
the technical part of that team and uh
the human proteome uh side and with
catherine leading that project um i also
want to thank obviously our wider
colleagues at deepmind like almost
everybody at deepmind in some way
contributed to this and also alphabet um
the collaborators at embol ebi cass
community and and also the pdb of course
in the experimental biology community
who um uh created those first 150 000
structures that then we were able to to
learn from
and i just wanted to mention about the
augmentation part so it turns out one of
the things we had to do with alpha fold
was do self distillation we're calling
self distillation where um we actually
train on 150 000 we um
output some predictions of some other
proteins and then we uh we sort of did a
filter on the high quality ones or at
least the ones alpha thought were higher
quality and we put that back in the
training set so and actually that helped
a lot uh we needed about 250 to 300 000
synthetic you know sort of synthetic in
this case predictions in the training
set was very helpful and quite important
to get the last few percentages out of
alpha fold
so i'm just going to end then by talking
a little bit a couple of slides on the
future um so now we're working on many
other uh related projects protein
complexes disorder proteins and point
mutations uh sort of mostly dynamics of
proteins you can think of and also
protein design so there's a whole area i
think that has been unfold unlocked uh
with alpha fold and we're going to push
further on and others are pushing
further on all these topics
and there's just an observation on
biology really which is that the more
i've worked on this and spent the last
five years looking at exquisite uh
biological system uh that goes on in our
bodies it's kind of amazing to think
that it can even work given its
complexity and i think that one way to
understand biology is it's fundamental
level it's an information processing
system i really believe that's the kind
of fundamental way to look at it but of
course life is a very
complex process
and it's an emergent process and i think
because of that it's pretty difficult to
describe mathematically in a kind of
clean way like if you think about trying
to describe a whole cell you know is
there ever going to be a newton's laws
of you know motion for a cell i don't
think so i think it's too complicated
and it's too emergent um so in a way
it could be the perfect regime for ai to
operate in and i sort of think
as maths is to physics you know mass is
like the perfect description language
for physics i think ai could be the
perfect description language for biology
and i hope that alpha fold will be not
just you know useful in itself but also
kind of proof of concept and of you know
maybe a heralding of a new dawn of what
i call another's called digital biology
and the dream would one day be maybe to
create a virtual cell that one could
make useful predictions in in silico
right obviously we're very far from that
but um you know alpha fold is maybe the
first tentative step and then of course
i haven't got time to talk about all of
these things but we've had a really uh
amazing year of applying um
these types of ai techniques to quantum
chemistry uh pure mathematics proving
some pretty major conjectures uh fusion
controlling the the plasma and a fusion
reactor and genomics uh and you know if
it sounds a little bit science fiction
this list you know these are all real
papers you can you can go and have a
look at them and this was always the
sort of flourishing that i had imagined
when we started deep mind was that if we
crack this in the right way this kind of
diet this kind of slide should be
possible even though it sort of seems
like perhaps sort of science fiction um
so i'll just end then by saying you know
my view ai uh used properly could be the
ultimate general purpose tool to help
scientists see further much like the
hubble telescope was for cosmologists to
see further into the universe thank you
very much